it's okay to be sad that doesn't mean
you're depressed it's okay to be worried
that doesn't mean you're anxious it's
okay to experience trauma that doesn't
mean you have PTSD not everything is a
diagnosable issue
so many people hide behind a diagnosis
and say I never have to get better this
is one of the biggest things with
attachment issues too people take an
attachment Styles quiz and say oh I'm
anxious attachment I will be that for
the rest of my life absolutely not that
is the medical system that says you have
a disease we must treat you for the rest
of your life you'll go through 10 years
of therapy and take five medications as
I was working as a psychologist as a
psychotherapist I did in-home treatment
for people and some of my clients were
on 27 different medications at the same
time and I would ask them what they were
for and they would not know and at least
12 to 15 of those medications would be
psychological medications some of them
were four or five different
antidepressants and then three or
different anxiety medications and then
some for panic disorder and then some
for who knows they just kept throwing
them in they had no idea that's the
American system right now and if you
have a diagnosis
it's not the end of your life and not
everything is a diagnosis a diagnosis
should just say here's where you're
starting where are you going to go
there's something very reassuring in a
way I think about pathologizing your
emotions about giving them a label it's
not that the world is unfair that life
is difficult that sometimes bad things
happen people pass away you become
destitute or broke or or ill or sick or
your family members die it's not that
it's that you have X or Y or Zed it is a
forcing function a convenient way to
reduce down the complexity of the world
and I see it in myself I see it in my
friends I see it in the people that talk
about this sort of stuff online
it is a very seductive solution to try
and have a label that you can place
behind something it's not that your
sleep pattern is very bad because of
your poor habits around eating late at
night which causes your digestive system
to cause you to not eat well and you're
drinking too much water and now you've
got uh like shy bladder syndrome or
you've got a like a a bladder problem
that means you've got to go to the
bathroom or whatever it is which is
causing your sleep to be bad which means
that Downstream from that your anxiety
is high the next day it's I'm anxious
I've got I've got anxiety I've got an
anxiety problem and um yeah reducing
down the complexity of the world into a
pathology ADHD we saw it before it's
like oh yeah giving that diagnosis the
number of ADHD diagnoses has gone up was
it like 10 times 50 times or something
that's overwhelming the amount in
America they say one in seven little
boys in America is now medicated for
ADHD I mean that's those are all brutal
medications do you know how many boys
I've talked to and grown men who are in
their 20s that say I've been medicated
for ADHD since I was four years old I've
been on I've been on stimulants since I
was four years old because my preschool
teacher diagnosed me with ADHD and told
them my parents they would kick me out
of school if I didn't get on meds a lot
guys have never lived their real life
what how would you describe I don't know
whether you've ever been on ADHD
medication but from what you know about
the experience of it what can you tell
me about
what life would be like before and after
for a young boy or girl and then also
moving up into adulthood
most of what I encounter is people whose
brain is so fried from years and years
and years of being doped up and
zombified and then still being screamed
at any time they twitch wrong they move
wrong they act wrong they don't do
something right it's you have ADHD
that's your ADHD get under control I
don't want to tolerate you you have this
problem people who have ADHD sometimes
it's not ADHD sometimes it's an
attachment issue other times people have
ADHD have attachment issues from being
yelled at for having actual ADHD it's
amazing how those two go hand in hand
and those medications zombify you and
then you've been on them for 20 years
and you've never experienced what it's
like not to be run down and also not to
be yelled at for having a diagnosis it's
it's not just even the meds it's the
whole experience of being told there is
something wrong with you and you will
never function right
what was that psychological experiment
where they
took children who had minor stutters and
emphasized the stutter yeah so they
encouraged one group and said hey
encourage them and the stutter got
better the other one they stressed them
out to the Max and it made it so bad
some of them couldn't even talk it was
100 if you encourage the heel ADHD by
the way some people call it type e
personality entrepreneur some people who
thrive in entrepreneurial settings have
very ADHD style brains and behaviors and
they can do amazing when you get them in
the right areas boys with with diagnosed
at least with ADHD do amazingly well in
non-traditional schools when you get
them in there their achievement goes
through the roof but that's not what
we're doing we're not focusing on that
because we have a one-size-fits-all
education model not everybody's got
access to a Waldorf School or some sort
of outdoorsy type thing which means that
if you are a child or a young boy or
perhaps a girl who has ADHD you are a
square peg being shoved into an
incredibly round hole and there are very
few Alternatives I think is it Elon Musk
who dropped out of Stamford after his
first seminar I think he I think he
lasted less than half a term or
something and you know you're looking at
a guy whatever you think of his
philosophy and his politics and his
businesses who is very capable at doing
a lot of diverse things that screams
just like uh weaponized commercialized
ADHD to me it is it is weaponized ADHD
is right and that's why he can achieve
the way he does most likely when you
harness it right it's an incredible
power when you live in a society where
everything is one size fits all then you
are a giant living in a City for very
short people and nothing is going to fit
right you're going to bang your head
everywhere you go let's also remember
that saying you know having an ADHD
problem every pathology that you want to
talk about is a spectrum you know even
the most focused person in the world is
the first percentile on the spectrum of
ADHD there's no point at which you hit a
marker and it's like oh at this point
you're ADHD even you could say this
about obesity right when you name
somebody as being obese it's actually a
kind of arbitrary line that's like okay
above BMI of this particular thing and
BMI is just this decision tool that
you've decided to use but we're talking
about Spectrum here and ADHD is a
function of a bunch of other uh like
phenomena and manifestations the way
that people behave and show up in the
world the same thing would be true for
anxiety for depression for whatever it
might be and
pathologizing it as well using it as a
label using it as an identifier is like
okay up to a point at what point do you
say that you're that you are ADHD or
that you're just somebody that happens
to have a more wandering imagination and
really how useful is it to be able to
get yourself to that set I mean Robert
Plowman what is he the third most cited
psychologist of the uh 20th century the
pre-eminent behavioral uh geneticist in
in the world
um he said that all of these diagnoses
as far as he can see are basically
pointless because everything's just a
spectrum so it makes it easy when you
want to diagnose somebody when you want
to come up with a solution but
it's not tremendously useful at them
understanding themselves because
everybody is on this spectrum everybody
has different bits of all of these
thrown in when I was at graduate school
one thing they told us was when do you
undiagnose someone and everyone in the
room looked around and said what do you
mean everyone when they get a diagnosis
they just have it and they said no you
undiagnosed them when in the book it
says when you can function well in your
relationships and you can function well
in school or work those are the two
requirements you must have functional
impairment from the issue if you can get
a person to where they are fully
functional they are no longer impaired
they no longer fit the diagnosis you
remove the diagnosis at that point and
say you no longer have this diagnosis
the problem is we have removed that
entire part from the book in our heads
and no one undiagnoses anymore and
diagnosis is now a permanent thing for
the rest of your life that is not even
built into the book that is built into
our culture so you just spend your time
accumulating and never ridding yourself
of different pathologies what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget get to
subscribe
peace
[Music]